الانتظار الى حين منح تشكيل الحكوميه
الاسرائيليه الثقه خلال هذه الكلمه التي
القاها بنيامين نتنياهو وقبل ذلك تم عرض
الخطوط العريضه لما تعتزم هذه الحكومه
الجديده اجراه وخطير المشهد السياسي
الجديد في اسرائيل حديث عن كل ذلك
مساء الخير المشهد الاسرائيلي يبدو انه
اكثر وضوحا اصبح بعد ان الفعل التامه
الكنافه الاسرائيلي والقناه بخطابه استعرض
امام او من على منبر الكنيسه استعرض من
خلاله الخطوط العريضه لحكمته المقبله
والتي تتجسد وتتخلص خاصه في همم جانبها
الاقصى اليمين على اعتبار ان هناك العديد
من الوزراء الغالبيه الوزراء الذين تتكون
منهم هذه الحكومه هم اكثر اسرائيلي ونعلم
بان سيكون على يمين بنيامين نتنياهو
المتطرف المتشدد بين كبير وعليه يساره
وهو احد قاده المستوطنين كما تحدثنا في
السابق على ذلك على
همم التوقعات ولاربما سياسه في هذه
الحكومه وان كان نتنياه يسعى الى ابداء
محاوله توازن في هذه القضايا اوكي تستمرها
للحكومه وكانتجنب الضغوطات الداخليه التي
بدات فعليا مشهد ان يكون هناك الالاف
ترابه ما يزيد عن الالفين من المعارضين
لهذه الحكومه قد تجمعوا قبال الكنيسه حيث
التامات ورفعوا في صفات حمله شعارات العار
لنتنياهو العار لهذه الحكومه عنصريه هذه
بدايه لربما التحركات والحركات الذي لا
يجب الاستعانه به ونتنياهو شيء ولذلك كانت
هناك بوادر لعصبيه لديه وهو على ما يقف
على منبر الكنيست وبدا في الحديث جلسه
صاحبه تمت مقاطعه خطاب لعندك
عمليات وصف له بانه شخص ضعيف بان حكومته
ضعيفه كل هذه الامور من قبل المعارضين
داخل الكنيسه فخارجها في ذلك تكون سهله
لبناء منها لانه هناك من سيكون له
بالمرصاد ليس على صعيد المعارضه
هذه القضيه هو الراي العام الاسرائيلي
والص طيب اسالي انهما سيكونان خير لربما
رقيب بهذه القضيه ونتناها يدرك بان
الصحافه الاسرائيليه تحدث الكثير من
التغيير لانها تكسب الكثير من ثقه الراي
العام الاسرائيلي ويبنى على تحليلاتها
وعلى ارائها وما تنشر لذلك هناك تحديات
كبيره امام هذه الاسرائيليه والاكثر ضعفا
فيها يبدو انه بنيامين الصيام
ليلى تحدثت عن هذه التحديات التي ستواجهها
باليمن على راس هذه الحكومه الجديده التي
توصف بالاكثر يمنيه في تاريخ اسرائيل ليس
فقط او لجهه ربما انها تكرر التوجهات
جديده جديده يمنيه متطرفه بشان حقوق
الفلسطينيين لكن ايضا بحقه حقوق
الاسرائيليين او جزء من المجتمع
الاسرائيلي
بالتالي هذه التحديات ربما تضعه على المحك
في بدايه هذه العهده ل- اا رئيس وزراء بعد
ان كان في المعارضه قبل ذلك
بالفعل هذه الحكومه ستمس كل شيء يتعلق
بالاسرائيلي الذي يعيش في كل المناطق
بمعنى التعليم هناك وزير التعليم هناك
خطوط عريضه ستكون متشدده هناك علامات
استفهام ما حول الزنج بشريعه اليهوديه
داخل الكتب التعليميه وان كان هذا سيتحقق
الزوج بتعاليم التوراه وكل هذه الامور
الدينيه في الكتب المدرسيه حتى اليه
التعليم شكل التعليم سيكون هناك بهذه
القضيه ليس على الجانب الفلسطيني فقط الذي
سيلاحق ايضا من خلال الكتب والمدارس
الفلسطينيه في مدينه القدس على اعتبار ان
مناهجها بحسب الحكومات الاسرائيليه
السابقه همم تغذي الارهاب لانها تتحدث في
بعضها عن الاسرى الفلسطينيين وما شابه ذلك
ولكن هذه الحكومه ايضا سوف التعريف لدى
الوسط اليهودي الاسرائيلي ما بين علي
العلماني واليهودي المتدين المدارس
الدينيه لمن ستكون الغلبه الصحه همم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه همم الطبابه عند صفحه
تعبير وهذا ما شاهدناه في بدايه حراك لعدد
كبير من الاطفاء في الاسرائيليين الذين
بداوا بث فيديوهات تعارض ما وصفوها
بعنصريه هذه الحكومه التي قدس قانون يعطي
الطبيب حريه تقديم العلاج للمريض او عدم
تقديمها هناك العديد حتى يوم السبت هناك
في هذه القضيه حريه ال- ال- الحياه
اليوميه تل ابيب لا تغلق ايام السبب
الحياه شبه عاديه بها هذه القضيه ايضا
ستكون محل اهتمام ووضع همم لكي تكون تل
ابيب هي ذات وضع القدس ان يكون هناك شلل
للحياه كم كم يوم السبت لاحترام لفرمته كل
هذه القضايا على نتنياهو مواجهتها اعتقد
ان نتنياهم سيكون اكثر تقييدا لانه بدا
اعطاءه كلها هذه الوزارات حتى من سيطرته
وسلطه على هذه الوزارات ولكل وزير اعتقد
انه ستكون له سياسته الخاصه جزيره